this mixer consists of a bin called a u
trough and an agitator it's controlled
by an interface module with simple start
and stop buttons the agitator shaft is
the main component its arms and paddles
turn at a speed of 10 to 50 rotations
per minute a discharge valve underneath
the u trough controls the unloading of
the mixture
first a hydraulic 40-ton press roll
forms a carbon steel sheet the sheet
rolls back and forth under the press
until it takes a u-shape an overhead
crane brings the sheet over to the end
plate for welding a worker spot welds
the sheet to the end plate a
high-definition plasma cutter burns
paddle shapes into a stainless steel
plate the extreme heat of the plasma
cuts right through the steel making very
precise lines and angles then the
paddles go to a forming press the 150
ton press pushes the plate down on a die
steel is a formable metal so it can bend
without cracking or breaking a slight
curvature in the paddles will maximize
the lifting and scooping effect of the
agitator a machinist turns the agitator
main shaft this tungsten carbide insert
can resist high temperatures and
maintain a sharp cutting edge
the machinist measures the diameter he
cuts a groove into the end of the shaft
using the stagger toothed side belt
cutter this groove called a key seat is
designed to lock the agitator to the
mixers drive gearbox a worker assembles
arms and paddles to an agitator shaft
mounted inside a Youth drop he bolts the
arms onto the shaft
he tightens the nuts with the pneumatic
torque driver and assembles paddles to
the arms both the paddles and arms are
angled machined slots in the paddles
allow clearance adjustment a worker
rotates the assembled shaft and arms to
check the clearance between the paddles
and you trough walls a welder creates a
solid stainless steel agitator shaft for
a larger mixer he welds the base of the
arms to the shaft and grinds down the
welding profile to obtain a uniform
shape welded agitators are often used in
food processing because they make
cleaning easier now workers attach an
electric motor to the mixer they mount
the drive assembly on the agitator shaft
a taper bushing centers the drive gear
box on the shaft a worker installs a
safety grade on top of the mixer and
closes the covers and he installs air
pressure regulators these supply air to
the main shaft seals
air purge seals prevent product loss or
contamination Airlines connect the
pressure regulators to both ends of the
main shaft agitator the mixer fits on a
support frame for easy access to the
discharge valve
it's equipped with clamps safety latches
and a control panel which includes an
emergency stop button